boom hello everyone welcome to
simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on and today
we're sitting down with Jacob ward hello
what's up are you sir so good to see you
again
I wasn't prepared for that I'm not
typically yeah to do a touch yeah that's
good
I'm more of a this guy yeah so we're
here with Jacob ward Jake and I met over
a year ago Jake came on our science
comedy show Eureka
Jake's backgrounds epic he's been
journalist correspondent with al-jazeera
with CNN with PBS author as well
definitely one of my favorite science
communicators always always making
science relatable asking the really good
question though I love that thanks man
it's so I had a I had a funny experience
where I was interviewing the man who
coined the term science communicator but
I didn't know it who was that and I was
giving yeah so um yeah now of course I'm
gonna blank on everyone's name it and
this can happen for the next 90 minutes
everyone really enjoys is me blanking on
name after name baruk fish-off is his
name and he's a psychologist and was a
very very different guy and he was
working for the National Academies
trying to come up with very he was
coming up with all kinds of fascinating
image of a smart guy and he he was
trying to come up with a term for what
this is you know how do you make science
legible to people yeah and he was and I
but the reason that I know this is I
spent the first like my icebreaker and
getting to know him was how much I
disliked the phrase science community
went off for a while thinking I was
being all charming and edgy with him and
and the truth is I think he didn't mind
it so much but but he he was like oh
it's what do you know I actually helped
to come up with that me oh and he said
that it was a matter of he didn't what
he thought that science there was
something like science instruction
was not the right or inspiration
inspiration too soft I think for the
National Academies and so science
communication for him was the clearest
way to say yes it won't be it's not
instructional it's not technical but it
is getting the importance of Acosta yes
once you describe it I was like oh okay
I get it I get it but yeah I think it's
a lot of syllables exactly that's a
mouthful and there is a more in a
nutshell way to explain it we'll figure
that out yeah every time they do what it
is exactly there's a neologism for
communicating science I like that yeah
so I'm really happy that you're coming
on a simulation because we are now
pairing together leaders with these
thought-provoking questions and we're
really diving deep across a wide
interdisciplinary array of subjects and
you're kind of the really ideal guest
for it thanks man and I kind of want to
start by talking about what you're up to
because I think it that'll lead us into
all those all the questions yeah Alan I
appreciate that yeah so you have a
podcast out on audible I do insist on
herbal so it's called complicated it is
the idea is that it is humanity's most
sort of pressing problems biggest
problems and the conceit of a lot of
media really all media since the dawn of
time was to try to you know boil things
down to their barest essence and I was
just finding in my in you know reporting
on science technology popular science
and then you know through working at al
Jazeera in other places that did you
know when you really get into these big
questions the big challenges everybody
in the end just goes oh it's complicated
just you and so I was trying to figure
out like okay I can't some of this stuff
up in three minutes it's just not
possible especially on television it's
it's not possible and so and so how do
you get kernels of the problem
articulated and interesting and the rest
of it you know how do you how do you
leave some questions unanswered in a
report and still get something important
across and so trying to sort of get the
confetti all over the room
the idea of that show and so it's you
know it's everything from opioids you
know we were still one of the first
people to really start thinking about
that back in Alger and then I got to do
some of that with with this robot ethics
you know big problems how are we gonna
feed twice the people on half the land
all that kind of stuff and so so it's
been great that's been a really fun
thing it's on all bolts behind a paywall
my apologies but there's sandals but
they're examples you can list a Sun and
and if you hopefully people so that and
then I have a show do that because the
like you started off by saying that why
is it called complicated because you
talk to so many professionals about it
and after even a couple hours of
discourse about it it's so complicated
so company like nuance it's complex it's
multivariate and so we're always trying
to calculate these dozens of variables
that go into not only things like
feeding the population or opiate
addiction these kind of things but even
something like politics and economics
here the state world is not just some
binary yes-or-no to immigration that's
right and just because you have your
finger on the dial of one of the
variables right you could turn it up or
turn it down does not mean that that's
going to solve the problem because any
one of those that you adjust is gonna
change all of the other things right so
with opiates the you know opioids are
such a difficult problem because you
know you talk about real pain management
for people people who otherwise die in
excruciating pain
we're getting a lot of relief from
opiates like that's not a that's no joke
but it that you know and and at the same
time you know I remember talking these
people at the Veterans Administration
and they were like you know we have so
many chronic pain sufferers they
estimated at the time that one in two of
their patients 50% of the patients were
coming in for some form of chronic pain
and you know and so we were talking
about I was asking you know what's the
you know is in physical therapy
they you know it's been proven in many
studies have shown in many studies to
that that it can manage pain better than
drugs can and they say well yeah but if
we you know if we tried to apply if she
said there is not enough physical
therapists in the world her is certainly
in the United States to service all of
the chronic pain sufferers that we have
coming through the VA every year so that
right there right
you can't just then be like well we tied
that one off you know yeah opioids but
now we get it you know then you got to
be like oh okay well why is the paint
why is the application and you know why
are drugs cheaper than physical therapy
and yeah and there's Cara it just like
it's sprawls and sprawls and sprawls
okay so all you can hope to do I think
in the show like that is to try to you
know at least you know encounter some of
the borders of the problem maybe you
want to be in the position I think to be
able to at least head off over the
simplistic solutions to this counts yes
that's the thing that I think people I
wonder if maybe you and I can think of
one of the best ways to address these
complicated subjects what is the essence
of the best way to bring a complicated
subject to the masses because maybe
there's we start with a statement and
that statement tries to summarize the
issue of let's say nuclear war or robot
ethics for feeding a question world a
question and it kind of summarizes the
really importance of in the essence of
it and then after that we kind of
propose maybe one or two points about
the heart the hardest parts about the
problem and then here are some of the
one or two of the solutions that are
being discussed for these problems
yeah so I just wonder what could be that
yeah I think that it's such a I mean I
think it's a it's a huge challenge I
think that you know as as quaint as it
is to say I think that telling stories
is the way that people learn yeah I
think people just that great stories are
there and and one of the great benefits
of the world that we live in right now
is it is possible to just to encounter
so many different kinds
amazing stories you can go out and
connect to people you know 100 years ago
we could never have understood anything
about you know so the the
interconnection of humanity I think can
help you do that so I love going and
finding you know I mean I think that the
the bad journalism builds a trend from
anecdotal evidence but if but if a trend
has been well established some big
scientific party has been well
established you can then go in and show
an anecdote that tells that story and at
least get people to understand what it
is I think you know so I don't have a
good example of but I mean I I really
like what you're doing here with these
sort of formatted questions because I
also think that you can I don't know I'm
a big fan I just like the way it's yeah
is when when people from you know when a
wide variety of different subjects are
subjected to the same yeah questions are
the same treatment every time I love
humans in New York for that reason yes
super formatted notion is one of three
styles of portraits and it's always this
one thing and it I love it man I can't
stop watching that so yeah exactly we're
designing the test track for the
brilliant minds of you yeah yeah exactly
it's the president's physical fitness
test yeah okay so oh man because I know
there's so many that you discuss and
complicated and I and I love unpacking
them maybe maybe before we get to
hacking your mind letter let's let's
dive into one of the ones and complicate
and we'll throw in a couple over the
simulation questions into it as we go
okay what who's going to teach robots
ethics there's a good one that's going
so so in complicated we did an episode
on on you know military ethics and
robotics and because it's a you know
it's just a handy example there's a lot
of activity going on in military
robotics you know a lot of stuff to
learn we did not
interview this guy for for it but but
one of the people that I met sort of in
in doing that kind of work was this pair
of researchers at Georgia Tech who are
literally trying to do that they are
literally trying to teach robots ethics
and in the sense in the sense that they
are they were they want the the robots
to learn from from us our ethics in the
same way that kids learn from their
parents ethics by reading them stories
so they grab stories from all across the
internet they crowdsource human
descriptions of things to then try to
teach the robot okay what is you know an
algorithm what is the decision-making
tree you should assemble to do this
properly and it's funded under an office
of naval research grant and a DARPA
grant because what they're hoping to do
in the long run is get non-technical
people to be able to teach robots how to
do things like program a vr environment
for Iraq right and how it's supposed to
look and so you bring in you know you
you want to be able to bring in someone
who knows an incredible amount of about
Iraq without them having to then also be
a coder and just say well there'll be
people over here and this is over here
and you don't talk to women whose faces
are covered and you know or whatever the
you know that you could teach the
cultural mores of the place plus you
know you you can really you can draw on
their primary specialty anyway so the
that's the sort of this the point of the
grant so they're trying to so they were
trying to create like this computer
program is called Quixote and they they
built a a game that was basically bank
robber and they were trying to teach it
to write scenes of bank robbery that
would make sense to humans by learning
those stories from the internet so they
got people on Mechanical Turk to write a
simple 60 I think is like a 60 word
story about here's how a bank robbery
wounds mystery characters the teller the
cop the robber you can do this you can
eat one has like a little you know a
group of decisions they can make and the
robot of the beginning was just having
the like the teller just like hand the
money to the robber
the robbers goes marching out the door
because that's you know the most logical
yeah that's
robot would do it and so then you you
instead get you you it began to learn
and it began to figure out like oh okay
and it began to write the thing we're
like the teller presses the alarm and
here come the cops and the chase is on
and you know they begin to look like a
Hollywood screenplay yeah like oh this
is it so I was just talking these guys
about like how how hard it is to do that
and they were like oh man it just goes
on and on you can't imagine how
complicated it is like ordering a
sandwich
is such a complicated set of decisions
when it comes to this kind stuff like
getting yourself a sandwich within a
shop for a robot no problem
jump over the counter you get back there
you elbow the human out of the way you
know you you make the sandwich you know
that the goals that you can build into
noggin are super straightforward but
instead you got to be like okay wait in
line don't cut the line yeah stand at
the register and even though the food's
over there you got to ask the person at
the register and ba ba ba ba ba you know
and one of the things the face that they
say about it is that one of their goals
is for the robot to not appear psychotic
to human beings all right and you're
it's one of those things we like right
because ya know so there's this whole
you know sub level of programming of you
know technical there's a technical
specialty in teaching people teaching
robots ethics that it I think is about
being like a whole huge profession yeah
that's right that's right
we just sort of well that's bigger
picture wats that's what I'm interested
in yeah doing for the next couple years
oh gosh I'm really happy that you kind
of let us down that in again a very
nuanced way because okay so check so
check this out you said that most people
don't think about the complexity of
walking into a line and then having to
stand at the back of the line in
vibration and
- not just totally hot as any as any
parent knows that's a hard conversation
to have with somebody with a kid you
know you got to be able to be like no no
no you don't do that that's right
and so yeah exactly so it's about
programming the ethics of even something
as simple as waiting in line or
something as simple as interacting with
the person behind the counter in a way
that's friendly or and in a way that is
efficient because there's a line going
on and so this was also interesting what
you described was that there's different
places in the world have different
cultural norms sure and because of that
then a artificial intelligence or a
robot might need to behave differently
yeah in those different parts of the
world or and that that in itself
requires the diversity of people from
around the world helping the programmers
figure out oh well when I'm in Europe I
act when I'm in the Middle East I act
when I'm waiting in line means different
things in different countries you go to
other countries and those the rules
about waiting in line are very very
different you know the English they love
to queue they love to stand in line you
know and
go to other parts the world and the line
is busy like everybody feels any
available space anyway but ya know
you're honestly right you got it you got
a so I think that's super interesting
but isn't it also interesting that like
we're gonna be trying to translate that
to algorithms which are gonna then
somehow make decisions that are going to
change the way we you know staying in
line will anybody stay on the line if
the algorithms stay it can stand in line
for you you know like dog image I mean I
don't know it's all gonna change so you
you you also brought up the the
complexity of how many people are now
going to be working on figuring out how
to kind of the whole Turing test because
you don't want this robot to be like may
I have a sandwich please you know you
you you want it to be almost
indistinguishable from humans and in the
way that it behaves in the way that the
flesh vehicle looks right um or maybe we
want it to be a complete piece of a punk
metal towel but the difference is the
research certainly shows so far that we
do not want to do to human right the
uncanny valley freaks people out like
you get too close to it being a real
looking thing have the reactor The Polar
Express reaction okay I want to ask you
about this now we like asking about the
geopolitical and economic race for
artificial intelligence
so what do you think about the United
States and China and other world powers
trying to procure the strongest code for
the future and where does that lead us
yeah so this is a it's funny I have many
interests around AI and that and you led
me into the one area that I know the
least about I mean I know enough I know
a certain I certainly know everybody is
attempting it everybody who has any kind
of super computing power and uh you know
and strong established traditions and
the technical sciences
you know he's into it right now I think
that there were some very concerted
efforts in certainly in China you know
they are they're the leaders of the
world's supercomputer race now and you
know you know are going hard at that I
think that it's gonna be very
interesting I think the way is that you
know AI as a sort of free-market
capitalist accelerant he's gonna present
itself here in the United States versus
how it's going to be used for you know
government support and the sort of
pacification of the populace and all
that kind of stuff in other countries
all of which is a form of sort of social
control and and so you know there are
people you
guy who's a networks specialist his lab
studies the movement of ideas across
groups of people and networks of people
and he says that whenever he finishes a
talk
there's no not whenever but he has had
times when he's finished talking he's
had somebody come up to him afterwards
and say it's so interesting what you
were saying about how to spread certain
ideas quickly through networks an
effective way could you tailor make the
message that gets adapted properly you
know because he was mostly studying
stuff like you know water Senate you
know sanitation good hygiene you know
health care like healthy practices
trying to get that information across a
network of people and instead this these
were people coming in being like how
could you move things forward you know
how could we move doctrine through the
group and there are different countries
the the person approaching him turned
out to be a representative of a foreign
government
you know you typically an autocratic I'm
looking for ways to do this so you know
I think there's there's obviously the
the horsepower is there for us as humans
to figure out this problem I think the
next being question that everybody's get
on top of now what's it gonna be used
for you know who's gonna be using it for
what reason yes yes because as I'd like
to discuss here you know like we are
powerless to resist it if it gets our
number right you know if it really gets
the number of the human of the way that
the human brain is built which is how
people are what people are really
figuring out right now if people figure
that out and then apply AI to it man we
are in real trouble
our you know we've got a really serious
problem so that's that's where my mind
goes
yeah I feel like the way that you see
the next couple of years and why you're
focused on this in the next couple of
years is exactly why I think other
people need to focus on at least having
discussions about where we're gonna go
with this No
so okay do you and let's maybe do one
last question within our national
intelligences I love it do you think
that artificial intelligence poses an
existential threat to humanity so this
is one of the I figured such a it's such
an interesting question and I think so I
think that there was a version of our
artificial intelligence as an
existential threat to humanity that I
don't know the common thread right that
I that you see in movies and then you
know people's writings and even notable
people Elon Musk and the rest you know
I've talked about is this idea of a sort
of a some sort of external force
enslaving humanity
a robot brain takes over humanity my
concern and this is the thing that I'm
working on for the next little while I'm
hoping to start a book on this subject
right away is how AI is is not going to
create a robot brain that controls us
it's gonna empower the wrong part of our
own brain and control us through it
exactly that's what it's gonna do yeah
so that's that's my big concern so I
think it is absolutely existential 39d
but not in the way that people imagined
and we have no idea how we can be
manipulated in all of ways that we have
no way no idea totally unconscious you
know the the ways in which you know and
and what's so interesting is when you
talk to there's so many very smart
people coming out of AI who are
realizing this right now that there
really is a sort of a code book for
human behavior and hacking your mind
that's showing up yes it's all about the
sort of the way that that bring the
human brain is built you know even
pre-modern people all the way through
the you and I sitting here we all have
the same rules that our brains follow in
making decisions and and the last 50 40
50 years of psychology is putting
teaching people that so once AI learns
those tricks yeah I say AI like some
external thing but instead when some
marketing person through uses AI using
those tricks yeah suddenly we're gonna
be powerless you know there's good I
mean powerless is the wrong word I don't
mean to be realistic about it I think we
are we're about to sort of I think we
need to undertake one of the greatest
media literacy campaigns and that's
exactly the world you know we need to
really get into some smart information
training it's crazy a we're already
seeing a little bit of them with the
bots that are on your internet that are
shirking certain content and echo
chambers and stuff like that totally
yeah oh all of the automated stuff on
Twitter you know the political
disinformation stuff that you see you
know that stuff is just using the most
simple rules of property to mess with
people right you know stuff written in
the 80s by you know
there's an amazing polish study on maybe
I can leave in the comments here the
super interesting about that's it from
this this think-tank in Poland that it
shows how you know back into the 80s and
90s Russians were were preparing you
know the the highest levels of Russian
academic and policymaking we're
preparing the doctrines that are now
being executed by these hordes of
Twitter BOTS
of you know find subjects that make
people emotional drive a wedge between
them using it it's the best way to
destabilize yeah enemy you know this is
pre internet yeah writings exactly and
they're just doing it you know this is
just part of deal and that's the most
crude form of that stuff I think when
you get into things like you know we
jump the gun here but that you know the
the unconscious ways that that our
brains register emotions from one
another pick up the emotions from one
another is so systemic and so totally
unconscious in us we you know when you
make a you know snake comes in here you
and I leave to our feet out the door
Lord it looks afar on that face
everybody in the room gets the sense
that something been terribly wrong
without even thinking about it because
it's all instinctive yes and it turns
out that you and I transmit emotions
yeah with unspoken unconscious
communication between our faces I go
freak out you go freak out you know
whatever it is yeah that's why when you
wink you know the other person can't
help but wink back yeah and you know
I've got me on the right over here I was
looking at the ads for for the iPhone 10
you know take a selfie everybody take a
selfie I'll mock your phone with you
with your face you know all that stuff
you know they're about to amass this
enormous database of how humans register
emotions on their faces and Wow you know
that's about sure I consider Africa
Apple a pretty ethical company but but I
don't know that it should be up to them
what they choose to do with that with
that data you know that's me there's a
really powerful thing
so once the algorithm you know can
identify micro-expressions and was in
2015 a paper came out that said
micro-expressions can be read better by
a robot they came
ian's that's trouble you know let me
look at my phone it's gonna know how
I'll do to talk to me and in the
language that makes me feel register the
emotion that's after it you know I this
is a perfect segue into hacking your
mind oh yeah yeah
so you just described that within
artificial intelligence one of the ways
that we could potentially be impacted
that is very not discuss too much is
that there's a whole myriad of
information about me that exists on the
internet already and just for an AI to
parse that information and then to be
able to send me an email and just say
like oh hey Alan by the way there's this
thing that I now know about you and
right without a joy I I know you no
choice and I have to do what is being
asked if that's right because they know
so much more about me than that because
of all the information I've put out over
the last whatever ten years this is
walking around just walking around right
so so with maybe tell us a little bit
about hacking your - yeah by the plies
yeah so hang your mind I I can't
describe two metrics a syllabus if we
haven't finished it yet but it's it's a
National Science foundation-funded show
about human decision-making and the
science of understanding behavior the
decisions we make and the big word big
operative word is bias yeah because in
science they were they use that word not
to describe just discrimination you know
racism sexism the rest of it but just
the shortcuts that your brain takes when
it goes from one thing to another
and our incredible ability to as I was
saying you know when a snake comes in
the room we just leap up and go exactly
we're biased you know that our biases
are TR giving us the power we need to
just get the hell out of here because of
the snake all for it and those you know
the theme of the show is essentially
there was an amazing amount of ancient
programming that has kept us alive for
millions of these satisfy yeah but now
we're living in a world where you know
we're doing things that our ancestors
never tried to do you know for tens of
thousands of years we have never you
know voted for people we've never met or
tried to police one another or you know
these things that our brains are not
built for we're good at danger avoidance
pattern recognition you know yeah you
know sneak detection yeah we're good at
that
you know we are not good at being fair
you know hiring the right people you
know those are totally modern creations
that were just not billed for so the
show describes all of the amazing
science that came out of people like
Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky baroque
fish-off there's no one Paul slovic all
these business whole cast a lot of
amazing women who do you bring them onto
the show yeah we get to talk to all
these on people and they're incredible
so they're incredible and their insights
are you know they've a so cool they're
so smart and that end the ways that I
mean and what's cool about the show is
that I get to be the guinea pig like you
want to see you want to learn how
unconscious most of our decisions are
you know try taking those experiments
and feeling or feeling you know
performing in exactly the same way that
everybody else does and you realize oh
my gosh you know I I really do have an
unconscious preference for people in my
age group yeah you know exactly you know
whatever just so for me the the the
impact of that show is understanding how
unconscious and powerful our
decision-making apparatus really is how
much I have been deluding myself without
choices I'm making yeah and then what
that means in the context of a world of
Facebook a world of Trump a world of
brexit the world with all these things
you know there's just a lot a lot of
stuff
that that you know happens when we try
to run a democracy using this ancient
apparatus and so so it's great I mean
it's been an amazing experience so out
of that we finished production on it and
we're in post-production now and and
wait here when it's gonna air but
supposing 2018 we're really excited
about that and is it a weekly with me or
one hour episode sports and big yeah I
don't you know I think so funny in this
day and age I'm on the one hand I'm like
I'm you know I I think it will probably
we keep it I don't actually know I have
no idea yeah yes on PBS is the idea but
we don't know yet but that's the plan
hopefully on YouTube or well that's the
thing and then it'll be it'll be it's
great oh my gosh yeah I think this is
just the start really without in your
mind though yeah I think so yeah so
actually Daniel Kahneman Commons book
thingy fascist little was one of the
most cool reads probably yes yeah the
baton ball
yeah problem yeah and Thinking Fast and
Slow so this is good I'm sure did he did
he ask you that the baton ball cost the
dollar and Ted says he didn't know he
because so Kahneman is sort of like
eminence agrees of the of the show and
the first you know Louie he just is sort
of he's just explaining a big
fundamental principles they bumped into
you know he and his partner Amos Tversky
is his colleague they were super closely
together
Percy then of course he died of cancer
in 96 but then but then Kahneman went on
to win the Nobel Prize and in economics
as a psychologist because really really
smart people do and he he in his Nobel
speech when I would have been like yeah
I want to know Bill he's like here's
what I'm doing next you know and he and
he described his interest in this idea
of a dual process theory said that there
had been all these people working on
this idea that we have
an unconscious mind that makes most of
our decisions for us and a conscious
mind that just rarely rarely gets
involved 17 times 24 mental map yeah
yeah no okay I have to slow down gotta
get system to involved and system one is
yes meanwhile you know driving your car
yeah you know buttoning your buttons for
you know making the food all that stuff
so anyway so yeah his his he's sort of
the center the center of the show or
that's all that's super cool
I love that question and for everyone at
home that might not know it yeah it's
the the baton ball a baseball bat and a
baseball cost a dollar and ten cents and
the baseball bat costs a dollar more
than the baseball and everyone
immediately goes ten cents that's how
much the baseball cost is ten cents but
it's not ten cents cuz ten cents plus a
dollar and ten cents would be a dollar
and 20 cents right so you're you have to
break it down okay well a base the
baseball would be five cents then
because the baseball bats a dollar and
five signing together there's a dollar
ten so and there's so many cool
questions like that that we can see
ourselves jump to the conclusion right
without even getting the chance to
process right why that's right he and
turski were basically trying to explore
the ways in which people when they're
when they're people who are not given
enough information and are strapped for
time or other resources
what shortcuts do they take you know to
try to solve complicated problems and
what they found across you know all
these different without thousands and
thousands of people per experiment and
their work is totally held up and been
substantiated we created by other people
is that we all do very similar things
and they begin to break it down and
these various specific biases and
heuristics yeah these patterns of
behavior and you know what is so amazing
I just love you know when you begin to
see those and see the pattern and then
look out in the world you just like oh
my gosh Wow
right that thing
yeah sure you know yeah so I saw about I
saw a chart of all the bias yeah there's
a great shorthand sure mapped and it's
just massive there's a whole whole world
of it yeah they're pulling them in from
all these in people the the one that I I
love is there's a hindsight bias and I
admitted earlier I did this amazing work
on asking experts ahead of an event the
likelihood of a certain outcome and then
after the event how confident they had
been that it how how likely it was that
that thing turned out that way the
Vietnam War ending away at the Nixon
strip yeah Nixon's trip to China like
you know and and he found that across
all these different people we not only
so we consistently overestimate the
likelihood of things that happen so when
my daughter says to me dad how could you
not have guessed that it's so obvious
yeah you know it's that kind of thing
you're like you're like oh you know I am
overestimating how likely it was that
that the axis one you know the Allies
won World War two and then and then it
turns out also that if you then ask
those experts to go back and recall
their predictions they consistently
underestimate or overestimate how likely
it was for that how likely they said it
would be so they overestimate their own
talent at making predictions which is
amazing and so and once you look at that
you're like yeah that's how I've lived
my entire life you know like I've
totally you know and that's how human
beings are like you know we are total
amnesiacs about about you know we don't
learn well from the past is basically
like the lesson of his research you
don't that's and once you once you serve
I mean what I love is that there's for
me the process of UNESCO is like is
there's this there's you there's this
resistance you have when you're told
this stuff about yourself you know you
just like no dude I'm not like that yeah
yeah I'm not like that you know no way
but it turns you know and then and then
you get
there and you're like wow I did exactly
what all the other humans did this is
just like how people are oh my gosh and
for me the it turns out there's a whole
research body research that shows that
as human beings we love a visual
illusion right you and I love the
funhouse mirror that changes our you
know body or the one where it looks as
if it's following you it's it's an
indented face right got into the wall
right and it looks like it's following
you as you walk by we people lo are
delighted by these by visual illusions
but the second you explain to somebody
their cognitive illusion like wow if you
do my face I'm not like that you know we
are densely defensive and so you throw
you throw a eye into that I mean that's
what I want to look at next
you throw a eye into that equation where
we have this incredible capacity to be
overconfident about our own
decision-making systems while relying on
a totally unconscious system that
follows really specific rules and can be
gained by a smart enough algorithm I
just think man we're real trouble like
we gotta get out in front of that you
know yeah so got to discuss it as
humanity yeah come up with some sort of
general principles around what what kind
of a future we want to miss with it
that's right
you're so right though about visual
illusions and how we're like ahaha
hilarious tricked me Dennis soon as
we're like here's a cognitive bias that
you experience every single day I do are
you sure yeah here's here's a place
where those things intersect I thought
was really insane though these they're
these vision researchers who were
looking at so forever people have been
exploring these dual process ideas the
idea that that your your your brain is
is receiving certain information
unconsciously on certain information
consciously and reacting in different
ways about so here's here's the example
so in World War one after World War one
there was an Austrian neuroscientist guy
this guy otto putzel
who was a you know a neuroscientist back
when you could not an image anybody you
know you really really cutting open
people's brains doing all kinds of crazy
tests on them and in this case it was
right after World War one where you had
your choice of all manner of crazy crazy
injured injuries and their effects on
people so in this case he was studying
people who had been shot in the head or
suffered some sort of horrible damage to
the head and wound up with with areas of
their eyesight that were blacked out you
know so big blind spots in their vision
and he was he was experimenting with
what they could see and not see and one
of the things that he would see or
wouldn't found with it was there's this
one guy named object I think was how you
say his name he's a veteran he'd been
shot through and had this perfect black
you know blackness in the middle of his
vision only had peripheral vision he
could describe it oh my god definitely
out used by you know have been terribly
wounded and putzel would put a picture
with pictures in front of him intent and
test him out on them and one of the
pictures was a bouquet of flowers and
like on a table and he was like I see a
room but he couldn't see the flowers
then he goes to the next picture which
is a little portrait of some people and
he says I see a group of people and the
man in the middle is wearing an enormous
bouquet of flowers pinned to his lapel
and and also goes back begins to study
do this of giving him sequences of
things and was was finding that that
images from one picture were arriving in
this person's consciousness when looking
at another picture and he developed this
whole idea of the piecemeal delivery
into consciousness I don't know how to
say it in German but that's what he was
investigating that our consciousness is
is like a train you know disgorging
passengers and they all go to work you
know and then when they get to their
desk the day begins but every all the
imagery takes a different train into
your brain you know
and and one the system is damaged then
they start to not arrive on the Senate
on time and it all gets messed up so so
the the that finding then led to all
these other findings about like the
unconscious delivery of information from
your senses into your brain and that's
sort of piecemeal yeah yeah so with
which can really easily be explained as
you walk down the street yeah probably
don't even really register people's
faces right what they're wearing or the
buildings or the cars anything I kind of
just see little icons right if anything
okay like your brain what your brains
really doing is like you know like
you're doing this you know in there
while you walk I mean that's what all
these people are finding and and you
know there was then a group of visual
researchers who figured out that if you
if you take in fact that same thing
where it's that illusion of the face cut
into the wall and it looks like it's
following you if you put you know let's
say it's cut into this wall in here
right if you put a little dot inside
there let's say a picture of a fly that
looks as if it's on the nose of the
person in there and you ask someone to
flick it off so they they it's crazy
they they will you know they'll totally
register the illusion be like well
that's crazy it's totally too fooling me
and then you'll ask them to flick it off
and their hand will go directly inside
will reach inside and perfectly flick
off the fly
blink without even thinking about it
which means that they're they determined
that there was an unconscious second
system visual system for for gauging
space and they call it seeing for doing
and seeing Forsyth's vision for doing a
vision for seeing or something like that
and and you know that so that thing of
having an unconscious experience of
reality you know and then this
incredibly limited got about no
conscious experience of reality are two
totally different things and like you
described a Google Robert Sapolsky book
behave really goes into neat detail with
this as well right just that it's been
ever
Cinelli programmed into us via our
nervous systems right sure damn thank
God right because that's why you and I
get to sit here together like otherwise
I mean you know my wife and I always
joke about the amnesiac like that you
know that human beings you know when
they're considering whether to have a
second child a lot of couples will be
like you know that wasn't so bad and the
wife you know the woman that will
especially be like oh that wasn't so bad
you know you know that wasn't so bad you
know we were we make of this joke about
how there's a little long ago
evolutionary branch of the tree that
remembers agony really well really well
it was like no we are not children maybe
we won't even have any children and
they're they're long dead that you know
they died out long ago you know and here
we you and I are the amnesiac yeah do
many people yeah that we've moved right
on through life you know never even
thought about it kept reproducing yes
you know but and then there was also the
bow honey we need another three workers
in the field at the bar okay so okay so
let's
that's amazing hacking your mind I'm
just so pumped yeah yeah I mean that
that's probably one of the most under
researched areas because we love the
brain but we don't like admitting we're
wrong or biased and so that's that's
gonna be really exciting okay let's
let's go into a a complicated question
about the brain but let's go into do you
think that what what is consciousness
that's a good one so so consciousness
let's see ah so I I don't know my my
answer is complicated but I think what I
would say is because there's been all
this really interesting work on on our
conscious brain and our unconscious
brain and these two systems a system on
a system to one thing that I think is
sort of for me
useful for thinking about this stuff is
the point at which our higher cognitive
functioning our higher reasoning what
these psychologist Daniel Kahneman and
the rest would call system to you know
it's our creative faculties our logic a
reason you know all of that stuff that
allowed us to make and harness fire and
you know make lights and buildings we're
wearing all that stuff is very recent
that system is incredibly recent in
evolutionary terms so we've only you
know we our our convergence with with
monkeys evolutionarily goes back tens of
millions of years and so the system that
we share with them is that old you know
at least that old and as a result has
had so much time for evolution to do its
thing and refine it and improve the code
and make it better and better you know
and make it one more foolproof yeah
whereas the the human higher reasoning
thing people think we've only really had
for probably like seventy thousand years
you know when we first came out of
Africa
yeah spread around the globe whatever
that dawning of our brain was that made
it happen
started you need all these other things
happen you know it made our big brains
possible off we go
you know I find myself thinking maybe
that it may be that's consciousness you
know maybe that's the consciousness in
the way that we think about and look
that but then I also think about you
know I got to spend some time with with
monkeys in this incredible habitat of
Cayo Santiago in Puerto Rico which was
ravaged by
if anybody wants to help them out please
do - I'm Tiago monkey island-- they he
spent he could spend time there and it's
1,200 rhesus monkeys that are just there
the only people longer the only beings
on this I hang out it's just you know
they're just everywhere yeah and they're
amazing is there in these little tribes
and and you know you can sort of hang
out with them and you know you look at
that anyway you spend time and you can
just speak that way the consciousness is
there I mean obviously it's there but
the researchers would point out that
that they those animals do not they
cannot transport themselves into the
experience of another one of their kind
and that that's the big one of the big
distinctions between Gans and monkeys so
a monkey could never in a million years
go sit in a movie theater and cry at a
movie about other monkeys you know it
can't imagine what you are like having
come here today you know from a
different route than it did or whatever
it is or imagine what life would be like
without the skill that it's had of the
group that it's had whatever it is so
yeah the researcher Laurie Santos is
this fascinating researcher out of Yale
she she says you know that when she goes
to yoga if people are like you know calm
your monkey mind
she's like no man it's not that it's the
human mind that's getting in the way she
said you guys all these stories about
sitting and eating food on a bluff with
a monkey and just be like the chillest
guy ever yeah so so I don't know I think
that that I think that consciousness has
to sort of run the gamut there
spans both of those experiences but you
know do we need that system to to be
conscious what is that level exactly
yeah we see it in even our dogs and sure
and then we see some sort of emotion and
consciousness and then we see some and
like you said I really appreciated what
you said about the evolutionary split
away from monkeys this because I think
that is an increased level and
consciousness is what a journal example
that you listed sure and then
furthermore building computers and
buildings and rockets and all this other
kind of stuff so besides like emotions
in empathy and and that kind of stuff in
understanding suffering right there's
also the technological advances so do
you think that it's localized in the
nervous system
yeah anatomically I mean so the the I
don't but I also know I mean I think
we're we're what do you think well I
mean you know I just think that we have
such a rudimentary understanding of how
the brain does its thing and and you
know there are researchers who are still
showing that that you know vision may
arrive at the brain by a multiple
pathways such that even if the main one
is severed as in the case of these
people was like lurking there
yeah so there's this amazing researcher
be it a Gelder at Columbia and she also
is in the Netherlands she she's studying
a condition called blind sight which is
incredible and so people who have lost
the connection between their visual
cortex sorry the visual cortex on that
and there
their machinery for seeing and basically
a stroke has produced a lesion that cut
it off and she's discovered all this
incredible stuff about you know where
people are she'll bring in somebody who
is blind
totally blind you know it says I'm blind
walks with a cane whole deal and then
we'll test them and there's this one
famous piece of video where where a
person picks their way busy she takes
the cane away from the sky and says and
that sounds worse than it is invites
this man to walk down this hallway
without his cane and he and they've set
up a little obstacle course in front of
him this is a blind man he's a comfort
have been accompanied there by his wife
you know he cannot see he stops at the
first obstacle he edges around it steps
around the next one goes down the hall
light goes around another thing gets to
the far end of the hall and everybody is
freaking out everybody's like how did
you do that to which he responds do what
he has no idea that he avoided all this
stuff and she's showing now that there
is there is that that part of the brain
that is root is somehow registering
these obstacles in the path is also
controlling has executive motor function
is controlling motor function without
this guy having any idea that it's
happening and he gets the other side
takes his cane back and thinks that he's
just sort of like got lucky walking down
the hallway you know so so the fact that
we don't even know how stuff arrives in
the brain that way it makes me go I
don't have any
we're in the brain that would be taking
these even yeah he's at one place where
is it a web of things there's a and
there's some recent one on mine filled
with Michael Stevens that I really liked
where they linked up an AI to the EEG
then had someone press a button and then
it would read when the signal came that
they were gonna press the button and
they would light the button up red and
they had to try and press it before it
was good yeah I love I love
consciousness and I loved automations
about what about the LED different
levels and stuff and I and I even like
hypothesizing about what it will be like
when we are even you know 1% genetically
superior than what we are now you know
what will that increased level in
consciousness
look like I don't know I think that for
me there's a whole transhumanism field
that I'm trying to be hip to and I just
don't get I don't get it yet quite I
have trouble decoding people's motives
about that I think and that's probably
what brings me up short but oh I get I
get in I get into I don't know I I seize
up with what's your biggest qualms with
transhumanism kind of like decoding what
why people want to merge with the
machine I just think it's I just I just
don't believe that human beings are
mature enough about death to really be
having that kind of conversation yeah
like you know we can't even talk in any
kind of straightforward or clear way
about at the end of our lives and we're
already talking about like cheating
death you know and handing ourselves off
to you know just to a platform
you know I just go we can't even we
can't even get our our heads right about
you know when is the time to die and how
do I take care of an elderly parent and
you know I mean we can't even do those
things yet and we're already talking
about handing ourselves off to robots so
for me I'm just like ah I'm not quite
ready for that let's solve these other
problems that's my first thing you know
and and it just it doesn't help that it
tends to be the very rich who talk about
that idea you know and and the very rich
and the very technically savvy and I go
I don't know man back I don't know well
now we have to talk about this go let's
go
is there a global ruling elite oh oh I
like that one so sure yes you know I
think you could look at the cast of
characters that show up at Davos the
rest of it and I think yes there are
certainly there's certainly human beings
that that have amassed outsized
influence over everybody else certainly
in economic terms that's true
you know I the staff that blew my mind
and and has become I feel like I want to
like tattoo it is the wrong word but I
want I I have it with me all the time
because it has is totally transformed
wonderfully the same one that's in my
mind well I wonder also in Mont mine is
a Pew study found that 49% of Americans
which is 50% of Americans 1 and 2 could
not get their hands on an extra $400 in
an emergency 400 bucks in cash they
can't get that Americans can't get an
extra 400 bucks
half Americans do not have an extra $400
to spare at any given moment which means
holy cow they have to borrow it from
somebody a family my whole or you know
yeah put it on a credit card or go to a
payday place or whatever it is right so
one in two so for me you know I just
think that the Wow there's a huge number
of people living you know I think active
paycheck you know and paycheck to
paycheck doesn't even cover it you know
that as soon as there's another paycheck
coming home because we're doing away
with those you know like some you know
people are really really in a desperate
shape and then so so for me I I look at
that and I think you know and then and
then you go and then you see the people
that you know have tremendous influence
in the world people who
you know the the the 1% as it were you
know the the contrast there was really
really really strong as you know as they
say though the ceiling in the floor
really falling away from each other and
so you know I I don't believe in grand
conspiracies of of people I think that
no you can't get three humans together
in a room and have them really
fundamentally agree about almost
anything and so I think the elaborate
orchestration of stuff is not as common
as we like to think it is but although
may be the implementation of centralized
banks well could be right with the right
technology you can make any coordination
like easier you know so that's right a
small small groups of people can have
outsized influence through technology we
know that I'll tell you about the
statistic that was in my mind was that
the eighth wealthiest people in the
world now have as much wealth as the
bottom three and a half billion there
you go so that we go and that was in my
mind and I think I think you the one
that you brought up is nuts as well
that's really interesting yeah exactly
yeah so ok so that's that's good so now
my follow up to global ruling elite is
should one endeavor to join the global
oh wow that's really interesting I don't
want to dodge this question but I would
say just to I think I would sort of say
that that you know what I try to do as a
dad and as a sort of a human
I just member when I was a kid my mom
took me in one night and saying some of
the happiest people I know are people
who have really powerful my mom is like
the great influence in my life she's
like I'm just a really really wise
person and she said some of the people
that I know whoever who are most content
in their lives are the people with a
really strong local I don't think she
said influence but sort of effect on
people's lives yeah talking about
Baker's she talked about school teachers
yeah firefighters people who who can
experience the connection to other
people yes have an ongoing relationship
with those people my mom not
constantly is a nurse that is that
relationship you know and and and that I
think is I think if everybody could have
the opportunity to do that and have a
little bit more than four times than the
K in the bank yeah you know at any given
moment that could be a really happy life
you know and I think with with you know
being on track as we are for eleven
billion people on this planet you know I
think much better to put away the theory
of exceptionalism and the desire to be
in the top one percent of whatever it is
and redefine lets you know redefine what
happiness is so that we can we can
actually have a good mathematical chance
of enjoying our symbols you know cuz we
can have lots and lots of good bakers in
this world you know we can't have that
many people know globally I mean there's
this guy this researcher at the
University of Alabama
this is my Tennessee by the way I want
to totally take a really upbeat topic
and turn it super dark so here I go
ready
so this guy Adam Lankford Alabama who
has been studying mass shooters and his
he's a fascinating person he was
connecting them to suicide bombers I'm
trying to figure out what some of the
psychological sort of threads are there
so with mass shooters he came up with
this theory of sort of why it is that
they are such a big deal in the United
States because the the rest of the
country you know the rest of the world
even countries that have tremendous
violence problems do not have lone wolf
mass shootings like we do and his he
came up with a bunch of things and that
Q stat was actually one of the mats
where I learned that was this idea that
people are so desperate but at the same
time are being led to believe by media
and their peers and you know social and
everything else that they're to believe
that they're going to become part of the
ruling elite right and he study about he
tried out this this study also appear
study showing that high school seniors
it was the stats are unbelievable like
25 percent of them believed they were
about to be famous right one in four
believe it they're right so that's a big
one
Wow huge numbers of them it's like half
or something like that were expected to
be
we're about to be have a great paying
job another you know 50% where were we
[ __ ] have a better life and their
parents did you know so this just out oh
I mean this unexplainable the optimism
of these standards they've been they'd
somehow thought they were gonna live up
to how could you not be disappointed
under those circumstances right yeah and
he also can you know point out the
incredible access to guns so this thing
of desperate circumstances American
exceptionalism crushing disappointment
huge access to come so that's where it
goes boom so you know crazy but that so
for me I think I just think like he's
identified one of the you know rather
than how to get rich let's all talk
about you know how can we be happy and
live sustainable lives with what we've
got because the math on yeah one in four
of us being famous doesn't work down no
you know it's just you know and also the
as you described with the I like to give
the example of you do scribe Baker's and
firefighters and people that are close
to their community I like to use the
example of what's the purpose of
purchasing a thirty yacht when you can
hire 50 people to solve a global problem
because one of them is going to be
giving you run with a I think I think I
just come up with stuff like that and I
try and plug it in I just try and see
how people react to it and and you know
and really on the 17th when we hosted
Jordan Peterson you know as a reply was
that one of them brings a tremendous
amount of meaing fulfillment if anyone
of high competence loves bringing and
helping other people they know that that
is a major part of fulfillment in life
and that's that mo maker or firefighter
community teacher writer's immunity so
the more people that you can impact
positively in the world the more
meaningful filament that brings you in
and so that's one thing about
endeavoring
that I care about is because I want to
bring that good to so many people that
meaning and fulfillment to so many
people right and I want to be a part of
the trajectory of Earth and where we're
going I want to be a part of the bigger
higher level decisions but like you said
it's crazy to see so many high schoolers
thinking that you know fame or fortune
or that those are not actually the big
things the impact is the big thing right
and how do we help communicate that to
young people that are using Instagram
and seeing all of the lavish stuff going
lawless lives with their colleague that
their friends and peers are yeah thing
that's right oh yeah for me I think and
I feel like this is not my expertise I'm
still just trying to figure this stuff
out but like but for me I think I think
it's just it's not trying to get
everybody to have a shoot as big an
impact as possible because that's a
really loud world like I feel like it's
got to be that you get you know that you
get a certain amount of satisfaction
doing a certain amount of good for other
people it's like you know people on
camera it was but somebody was pointing
out on Twitter you know they feel really
positively about not just the immigrants
who have a you know a crazy amazing
story about how they you know you're a
brain cancer or whatever it is but it
was something about you know like it I
like the ones who'd like to sit home and
and watch TV and eat some chips
sometimes you know I'm like yeah and
that's right like people who just like
that want to be people hang out well
example like I'm totally and that is the
media doesn't sell exceptionally clear
that I'm that's me I'm doing so maybe
there needs to be some sort of
restructuring of media to I to highlight
that it's totally cool to relax and find
fulfillment in just you know playing
with your kids
and you know I mean this is something
you know this is one of the things that
comes up a lot in hacking reminders sort
of one of the lessons of the of the
findings that those all of that that
that world of psychologists and
researchers and behavioral economists
anybody has come up with is that one of
the big challenges that we're gonna face
is that the really the you know the the
most logical the best thing to do to
preserve democracy or to you know
maximize you know your financial
security or whatever it is the thing
that you should do feels the worst it
isn't it doesn't necessarily feel good
to do the right thing it certainly it
very often doesn't certainly doesn't
make a very good story you get a higher
reward circuitry from doing something
the short term dopamine reward versus
totally you're taking advantage of this
executive functioning and saying right
it's a delay my grab it's a boring movie
when you're when you're thinking it
through you know when neo in the matrix
says you know I know he's being held in
a military facility and I know that he's
surround with me I know no one's ever
come back alive again stages before but
I I but I believe in something and
they're like what do you believe in neo
and he's like he's like I believe I can
bring him back and that is the same
narrative you see in every movie you're
hearing it from a president right now
all the time like I make decisions with
my gut my gut tells me what to do on my
gut kind of guy you know and that feels
best so you know your the thing your gut
is gonna make the decision that feels
best but it turns out that that's not
actually the right decision to make you
know like the and and the the movie
where neo is like let's not go in there
that's a really bad idea we're all gonna
die you know nobody wants to watch that
movie and so over and over again we're
being conditioned by movies and reports
and everything else to believe that we
should be like that we should be doing
the thing that feels right you know when
in fact the thing that feels right is
very off on the wrong
so for me I do that dosnt packaged up
very well and I don't know quite how to
sell that as a credo it's not a very
good t-shirt doing the right thing feels
mad yeah you know it's not a good credo
but that's fundamentally what a lot of
these people are discovering that's what
these psychologists are figuring out and
so what are we gonna do about that
mm-hmm
we're so good at packaging good feelings
yeah all right let's do a couple
slightly quick quick keys at the end how
how about could you alien some sorts of
yeah I also want to hear you thing about
alias because I don't know your I don't
know your feelings on that subject
you know galleries heard enough of your
we were right there going right there
all right are we alone in the cosmos
sweet I love it I love it so so the math
as you well know says of course we're
not there's has to be other other beings
out there and you know the Fermi's
paradox is the whole thing ready to do
so there's all these stars the math
should be that there should be somebody
else so I camera who it was but there's
some some pair of you know PhD students
or something I think in the Netherlands
came up with a great answer to that to
Fermi's paradox which was sure they're
there you know alien life begs be
popping up all over the universe but why
should we assume that it would be
popping up at the same time that we are
alive here on earth yes that if you
actually look at the sheer amount of
time that has passed which is the one
thing that humanity is one thing that
the brain is really bad at grokking yeah
is huge amounts of time is why nobody
can get their mind around evolution yeah
we can't imagine like oh right there
have been aliens but they died out 20
million years ago you know or whatever
you know they may have you know buzzed
right by us at some point but we
wouldn't know because we've been alive
for the equivalent of a match being live
you know that's how long we'll be around
yes planet and the galactic center
actually a love time so so I think sure
sure but we may not be around to see
them we may never have the capacity to
really understand you know to detect
them I mean who knows you know so here's
a couple things is that the amount of
habitable planets that orbit stars in
the habitable zone is about we
approximately one in every five stars
has so about 20% phasing crazy that's in
this habitable zone and right now most
stars are dwarf stars and smaller than
ours so the habitable zones closer to
the planet right so like you said that
there's on this timescale that we could
have had an evolution of bacteria of you
could have an evolution of some plans oh
you could have never exactly and you
never know let's say an advanced
civilization did evolve now let's say we
are getting close to this advanced
civilization right Fermi paradox speaks
of all of the Fermi filters so all of
the different diseases or asteroids or I
like that movie I'd watch that movie
where the diseases the diseases that
come through to us from sorry go ahead
and then there's a new nuclear war
there's the artificial intelligence
Fermi filters so there's all these
different Fermi filters that prevent
civilizations from actually scaling into
the dozens of millions of years of life
and and colonizing other planets and
stars and so I love thinking about this
question and all the different levels of
consciousness that could have evolved
across all these different stars but I
do think that because of the vastness
and because of the time scale then there
must be one that figured out how to
harvest the power of their star and
go and colonize other planets right and
so there's a whole like zoo hypothesis
as well which is that the advanced
civilizations are observing the ones
that aren't advanced and they're waiting
for the ones that aren't advanced to do
things like figure out how to travel at
the speed of light or or teleport and as
soon as the unlock that feature then
they talk to that member what I like
that idea right it's I think it's no
coincidence that like there's this
incredible promise of a great thing
right around the corner in that idea the
human brain loved civilization yeah okay
that's right so I like that one a lot
I think the the only other thing I would
say is like really imaged in the the
exoplanet stuff and then yeah and I
favorite thing to do is when they when
the Kepler data generate you know costs
up a new one these two then try to take
the Lightyear distance and be like okay
you know with the Space Shuttle how long
would that take to get there and looking
so long laser propulsion is getting much
more interesting and much totally faster
and totally really exciting stuff where
there's good work being done at the
University in Santa Barbara California
Santa Barbara where they're able to send
a 1 kilogram package to Mars via laser
propulsion in less than a day oh wow wow
but then there needs to be the receiving
yeah I got it I got it no no no I don't
it's gone so it's incredible for being
able to resupply yeah I love the idea of
preserving the light of consciousness
and I to getting to the next rock just
in case I'm and I and I love that yeah I
do I believe in society expanding there
and terraforming and making another home
like that
and also making homes in space and stuff
like that but I also am very aware of
needing to have the conversations about
the potential speciation or bifurcation
of civilization into the wealthy that
can live on space or transit across
space and about Damon yeah I mean yeah I
like yeah that's interesting uh you know
for me I think I just I find it so hard
to imagine just because space is you
know space wants to kill you you know
supposed to kill you so bad you know and
it has so many ways of doing it I've I
worked with a fabulous data illustrator
named Katey peek at a popular science
and her husband studied the interstellar
medium so what is space and I was like
what does that even mean and she said
well what if you if you drag your hand
if you were driving through space with
your window down and you held a white
and you have white gloves on and you
stuck your hand out what would it come
back like I was like well it'll come
back and she's like I'm come back filthy
ya filthy
that's supposedly that space is dirty
and full of stuff and so just that alone
like like Stardust is that just stuff
like and and he studies what it all is
and I would I couldn't even tell you
what it all is you know but he but you
know flying through that for whatever
it's gonna be you know a year and a half
round trip to get to Mars oh there's a
lot that can go wrong I all love idea of
Bora Bora you know I don't it's gonna
take thousands of thousands of years to
be able to terraform to that to that
degree so ok well another quickie before
we before we end yeah is this been great
by the way I really appreciate it I
really enjoyed those we'll have to have
more sessions because we only chunked
out like three percent of the questions
so okay how about maximizing human
so what are some of your best strategies
for that maximizing human potential as a
species like what are we gonna do and it
may be even at the individual level as
well like what about raising a child
into the world
oh my gosh who knows as a father of two
I can say right now no that's how you do
that you know I think so much of my life
and so much of everybody's life is just
muddling through and then you look back
on it and be like oh that was a cogent
narrative really what I was doing you
know at science a bias and so God knows
I live a lot of my life that way you
know I think that maximizing human
potential on earth well I mean I will
say that like the trajectory of human
sort of individualized human benefit is
is going up you know and I think the
thing that we sort of forget because
we're constantly trying to sell each
other stories of doom and gloom and
horror and get each other's attention
that way is it's easy to forget that we
live in like a piece of the most
peaceful most prosperous age in the
history of humanity it's getting worse
it's getting better and education
everybody's you know and so that said
there are screaming huge fundamental
threats to to human society and you know
the habitability of the planet and all
kinds of stuff but you know we're doing
pretty good you know for for when I
Drive down the highway and I and I see
all the people around me stick into
their Lane you know nobody I mean
obviously there's distracted driving is
over but the fact that like that at any
given moment somebody isn't on fire in
that moment you're driving along 60
miles an hour you know the incredible
human capacity to live in peace with
other people yeah with obviously huge
exceptions and horrific exception yes
you know and and the amount of localized
conflict is going up that's a real
problem right now instead of like
conflict researchers will tell you that
they you know a couple decades ago could
keep track of the major conflicts in the
world and now and that's really hard to
keep track of yes so many people falling
out of us themselves yes and that make
it worse like those you know I'm not
saying it's all good news but you know I
think if we
if we redefine this you know happiness
certainly in this country if we can you
know solve some food problems because
those are coming and I think if we can
get better at understanding I mean this
is the big one for me is if human beings
can get better at understanding those
sort of mental patterns that we follow
yes if you can become versed in those
and even play them off against each
other because that's the thing that
biased researchers will tell you is that
the you know your your biases and again
using that in a kind of scientific sense
not just in the sort of discrimination
kind of sense but your the shortcuts
your brain takes you can harness those
and do all kinds of cool stuff with it
you know I talk regularly with my
daughters who were four and six about
this and might find younger daughter
jokes that she's trying to trick her
brain in cleaning her room so cool so
smart yeah and and and you and you you
know you and when she did that I just
was like yeah great job that's right
that's exactly the kind of thing we're
gonna be able do so I think if we can
learn our capacity for being manipulated
and learn the tricks of making good you
know of tricking our our system one into
making good decisions that's gonna be a
really powerful powerful thing I could
do some good stuff with that you know so
yeah and I hope that we can get to a
point where we're educating more and
more children about this on the planet
because the parent is kind of the god to
the child when the child's born into the
world and to just hand it off to other
people to be responsible it's wrong
trying and so to do our best to bring
maybe things like evolution and bias and
morality and the brain in the heart and
the anatomy spirituality to a young
child when we're born into the world
might definitely help us maximize their
potential in a world filled with AI and
all the of the future that's right
that's right I think that too so alright
last question yeah are we to computer
simulation so so my feeling about that
is not one that has been constructed by
some sort of outside
worst to test us you know I don't
believe in the zoo idea that we're all
kind of running around this part of him
some choreographed menagerie but you
know like I was describing before this
stuff about you know generations now of
psychologists and neuroscientists have
established that our brains are
delivering information to us not as it
happens but you know through an
elaborate system that then delivers a
feeling of reality into and of the
present moment yeah into our brain yeah
and it's true
sight it's true of hearing it's true of
all forms of all kinds of cognition that
you're you you have a conscious and an
unconscious system after you know from
using your hearing your sight your
thoughts whatever so no I don't believe
it we're being that you know we're in
the matrix but I do think that we have
the tremendous you know that that her
great talent is not he's not absorbing
reality as it really is happening
because it would be too much for a
little for our brands you know we we
have a system for mediating at all
before it reaches us and that system has
been really really useful my only
problem is you know if we if we aren't
careful we're gonna build systems and
more importantly business models and
governmental policy and the rest of it
that's gonna that's gonna you know the
will be a simulation in a way that will
drive our decision-making for us you
know we're seeing that happening now
through AI specifically but through the
systems of control that human beings
build for one another that's the start
you know we're we're getting really good
at gaming each other yeah so we I think
striking out of the simulation breaking
it getting out of side of it I don't
know I just I think there's a great
human capacity for that I remember I
remember playing I was fasting for a
while by the subculture of people who
play the you know would play the
original Call of Duty or of those games
you know they go in there's two issues
the must move but any anything happen to
Reno that you do to strategy games
really games anything any sort of
sandbox kind of game yeah and and the
people who were then who would then you
know glitchers who would then go and try
to get out beyond the wall yeah example
they try to get beyond those fake bombs
in the background and and find these
places where they were like skipping out
on the reality of this place it made it
so one thing I like about is that I
think that the more we try to fool each
other and the more that we try to
manipulate each other we could take some
confidence you know some reason shows
from the idea that human beings love to
break the model they love you jump
outside
yeah yeah so I hope that that is one of
many things that save us nature is our
desire to get past the edges of what we
think is reality and that's kind of also
tying it back all the way to what an AI
could know about us that we don't know
about
even our selves and then finding that
thing on the outside right love I love
that I think that is definitely a part
of the simulation conversation is what
is the current manifested world and then
what is outside of that that's right how
could that potentially be advantageous
to for my understanding your
understanding and our understanding
collectively right our perception system
is so fascinatingly both advanced in so
many ways but also so limited
interestingly and then we have all these
augmentations to our perception system
that were working on to be able to
see other parts of the electric make
spectrum or to be able sure feel words
on our body you know all those
additional kinds of things that I think
will get us closer to this what could
potentially end up being a supercomputer
powered by the star yeah yeah it was
open there's open I like your vision
better than my vision and I think I
think that general understanding of a
supercomputer power by star kind of
gives a little bit more reality to what
a simulation could actually be like or
even nuclear fusion like just being able
to fuse atoms and then take a more
energy out than it we put in that whole
process and repeating that for energy is
just that's an abundant source of energy
for civilization forever to travel the
Stars to do whatever we want as well
so I think that we covered so so much
yes so much I'm so grateful I don't you
so guys Jacob Ward is on Twitter we're
gonna put his link inside of the
description that you guys can find also
we would like to again ask you to check
out complicated on audible
SuperDuper good who's doing yes yes
hacking your mind will be out soon we
want to thank our director and producer
Ron Vargas for being epic crushing it
behind the TriCaster and Robo cams we
want to thank River Studios for their
beautiful space they're amazing as well
we'll throw their link in the
description and guys if you guys had a
good time please do give us a like give
us the comments give us a subscribe
share it with other people
we're on patreon so if you want to
support us please become a patron you
get tons of great benefits you get
access to knowing who our guests are
ahead of time access to exclusive
content access to events ahead of time
all this kind of exclusivity that we'd
love for you to join the conversation
with us on again
Malon sake and this has been simulation
with jake ward and we'll catch you guys
soon
placement thank you very much yeah